comme chaque mercredi maintenant nous
partons à la découverte d'une école dans
les Yvelines et c'est avec vous réginera
lèche vous allez nous parler de l'ESTACA
ce soir tout à fait Mathilde je vais
vous parler de l'ESTACA cette école
fondée en 1925 forme des ingénieurs dans
le domaine des transports et tous les
transports puisque les filières
proposées passent par le domaine de
l'aéronautique le ferroviaire
l'aérospatiale l'automobile ou encore la
filière navale les staccas est aussi
trois campus en France à Laval à
Bordeaux et à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
depuis 2015 elle compte également 2600
étudiants 400 diplômés chaque année et
40 associations étudiantes elle présente
également d'excellents chiffres puisque
98% des étudiants sont embauchés dans
les deux mois qui suivent la remise des
diplômes et elle se place à la 9e
position des écoles d'ingénieurs
post-bac par l'Usine Nouvelle les stacs
comptent également d'anciens élèves
notoires on peut citer par exemple
Frédéric Vasseur le nouveau directeur de
la de la Scud Ferrari pour en parler de
cette école on est avec nous un ancien
étudiant il n'a pas encore la carrière
de Frédéric Vasseur mais on lui souhaite
lui Orthus on va parler un peu de votre
parcours vous êtes ingénieur en
amélioration continue qu'est-ce que
c'est alors en amélioration continue il
y a plusieurs rôles souvent qu'on est
dans une entreprise dans ce type de
poste là où je suis donc à prendre en
juin j'ai on va dire deux grands rôles
c'est tout d'abord d'être au contact des
opérateurs toute la journée donc essayer
de remonter le plus possible les
problèmes qui peut y avoir par rapport
au système de production qu'on a mis en
place et puis il y a une autre partie on
va faire de l'implantation de chantier
c'est à dire mettre en place des
nouvelles lignes de production et
essayer de les améliorer au fur et à
mesure pour que les loisirs que toutes
les personnes qui travaillent dans le
système de production travaille dans des
manières de manière qualitative avec des
bons rendements et puis avec la plus
grande sécurité possible aussi et alors
comment est-ce que vous avez intégré
l'ESTACA alors les stockages donc je
l'ai intégré donc c'est une école qui
est post-bac de base donc j'ai fait
évidemment une termin scientifique avec
une option physique-chimie et donc après
je l'ai intégré avec donc parcoursup en
faisant ma demande donc à l'époque je
crois que ça plaît encore APB admission
post-bac et donc à ce moment-là j'ai
fait la demande directement sur APB et
j'ai été pris ce qu'on appelle en grand
classique c'est-à-dire que je n'ai pas
eu à passer le concours parce qu'il faut
savoir que pour entrer dans cette école
en fait faut passer normalement concours
qui s'appelle concours à venir et donc
les personnes qui ont un dossier
suffisant peuvent ne pas passer ce
concours et directement être pris sur
dossier d'accord
donc vous vous avez été pris parce que
vous aviez une bonne moyenne oui c'est
ça après ça dépend aussi du lycée dans
lequel on est souvent ils vont faire on
va dire une moyenne entre on va dire
notre position dans la classe parce
qu'ils ont accès au moyen des autres
aussi et puis le lycée d'où on vient qui
peut aussi jouer dans le dossier est-ce
que vous avez des conseils pour passer
une bonne scolarité au sein de l'estaqua
on passe une bonne scolarité le conseil
que j'ai c'est d'un point de vue
scolaire c'est d'abord d'être vraiment
assidu sur en tout cas elle est vraiment
les premières années parce que c'est une
école qui est vraiment pas facile enfin
après moi je l'ai vécu comme ça il y en
a certains ils ont vécu une manière
différente c'est une école qui va être
très dure tous les deux premières années
parce que c'est une prépa intégrée en
fait donc un peu comme quand on fait une
prépa et on intègre une grande école
derrière donc surtout sur les premières
années et puis après ne pas hésiter à
vraiment aller dans les associations
découvrir tout ça parce que ça permet de
se faire des contacts ça permet de
d'apprendre de l'expérience et surtout
ça qui nous sert après derrière dans
notre métier et justement vous avez
choisi quelle filière j'ai choisi la
filière aéronautique et ça on l'a choisi
donc c'est une filière qui choisit en
troisième année d'école
alors dans cette filière on va voir
plusieurs alors ça dépend des années
mais sur les premières années par
rapport par exemple à l'aéronautique on
va d'abord travailler sur des projets
qui sont type aéronautique mais aussi
les matières assez scolaires vont être
orientés vers vers l'aéronautique
on a eu l'occasion de travailler avec
aussi des entreprises sur des projets
différentes entreprises c'est un on va
dire une expérience qu'on a en 4e année
c'est un gros projet qu'on a toute
l'année et qui nous permet en fait de
d'être au contact avec une entreprise et
de réaliser un projet avec l'entreprise
et donc aujourd'hui vous évoluez dans le
domaine de l'armée pourquoi est-ce que
vous avez fait ce choix j'ai fait soit
parce que je l'ai découvert leur dans
mon stage de deuxième année j'avais
réalisé au chantier Atlantique qui est
donc une grande entreprise très dans le
domaine naval qui est basé à
Saint-Nazaire et durant ce stage en fait
j'ai travaillé sur un projet militaire
et c'est ça qui m'a directement donné
envie de travailler dans le domaine de
la défense parce qu'il faut savoir que
par exemple même dans l'aéronautique il
y a une grande partie civile évidemment
mais il y a aussi une grande partie
militaire qui est de plus en plus
importante surtout avec la situation
actuelle donc vous êtes rentré en stage
est-ce que c'est difficile justement de
trouver des stages dans dans ces
filières de manière générale alors ça
peut être difficile comme
on va dire que depuis le la crise du
covid ça a été un peu compliqué de
trouver de trouver des stages après ça
va on s'améliorant de plus en plus avant
le covid c'était très très facile que ce
soit dans l'automobile aéronautique le
ferroviaire mais on va dire depuis où
elle 2020 c'est un peu plus compliqué
mais ça commence à revenir surtout dans
le domaine aéronautique où il y a de
plus en plus d'offres donc faut vraiment
pas hésiter à aller sur le site des
entreprises et à passer aussi par en
tout cas je parle pour les stickers par
la partie on va dire un peu RH de
l'estaquais qui nous permet de créer des
dossiers d'envoyer à certaines
entreprises il faut vraiment se
renseigner là-dessus
en rentrant dans cette école du coup
quand on en sort justement qu'est-ce
qu'il y a comme métier concret par
exemple dans l'aéronautique ou dans le
ferroviaire
comme métier concret un des métiers les
plus concrets c'est business manager
c'est souvent des gens qui vont aller
donc ça c'est beaucoup il y a beaucoup
de postes comme ça qui nous sont
proposés donc on va aller au contact des
grandes entreprises pour un
sous-traitant et on va un peu voyager ça
c'est un peu souvent qui fait un peu
rêver on est souvent amené à voyager
pour aller au contact des clients pour
comprendre leurs besoins et puis pouvoir
créer du coup derrière ces besoins dans
l'entreprise
ou alors par exemple un peu ce qui que
j'aurais pu aussi faire c'était de
l'exploitation et maintenant c'est à
dire être par exemple dans des ateliers
aéronautiques par exemple chez je vais
pas citer le nom mais je suis une grande
compagnie aérienne où on va être donc au
contact des hommes toute la journée avec
les opérateurs pour pouvoir pour pouvoir
un peu étudier comment améliorer la
maintenance des moteurs la maintenance
de l'avion en général donc ça c'est des
postes qui sont assez concrets et qui
nous sont proposés directement après
après notre cursus tout à l'heure selon
vous c'est quoi la force de l'ESTACA on
entendu les chiffres 98% de réussite
mais ce que il y a autre chose
alors l'ESTACA c'est une entreprise qui
se déjà depuis longtemps donc c'est
forgé un réseau dans les grandes
entreprises ce qui fait que maintenant
quand on va dans une grande entreprise
les stockage souvent une école qui est
connue donc ça ça nous aide souvent sur
on va dire nos entretiens forcément mais
du coup on a aussi de derrière on a
aussi un peu stressé par rapport à ça
parce qu'il y a une attente derrière des
entreprises de voir quand même une
qualité sur sur tous les on fait tous
les points qu'on doit aborder lors des
entretiens mais je pense que c'est quoi
ce qui fait la force c'est la renommée
et puis et puis en vrai le panel de
choses qu'on voit quand même en 5 ans
même si c'est jamais assez suffisant sur
cinq ans on s'en rend compte quand on
sort de l'école mais ouais la grande
force de stockage je pense que c'est
tout ce qui est renommé voilà alors
rapidement dernière question ça coûte
combien les frais de scolarité dans
cette école c'est autour des donc pour
les cinq ans c'est autour des
40.000 euros et ça commence à un peu
évoluer depuis quelques années comme
beaucoup d'écoles donc voilà autour des
40 000 euros pour les 5 ans après on
peut rentrer aussi en troisième année
après un autre cursus par exemple une
prépa donc on paiera que les trois
années par exemple mais si on veut
rentrer dès le bas enfin juste après le
bac c'est simple enfin c'est 40 000 €
pour les 5 ans merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté notre invitation et d'être venu
parler de votre ancienne école l'ESTACA
on vous souhaite beaucoup de réussite
merci